oui j'ai été un peu surpris évidemment
de
son choix d'ouverture je m'attendais
soit une
rue française rubinstein soit swing time
and off est évidemment j'ai voulu éviter
un peu ses préparations je suis rentré
dans une position à double tranchant et
j'étais pas certain non plus de ce que
je faisais mais au final ça s'est très
bien passé parce qu'il y réfléchissait
beaucoup je voyais qu'il était pas dans
une situation confortable et rapidement
j'ai su que j'avais une décompensation
amplement suffisante pour le pion et
j'ai lu j'ai récupéré les pions avec les
intérêts et aujourd'hui enfin si
aujourd'hui j'étais un peu surpris par
son choix d'ouverture j'avais anticipé
petits pouvaient jouer la ligne h3 mais
pas pas de cette manière et je sais pas
si j'ai réussi de la manière la plus
précise ma position semblait assez
enfin semblait tenir mais
et vraiment
par un fil dans certaines lignes donc je
n'étais pas certain non plus de ce que
je faisais mais au final plus réfléchie
c'est plus je voyais qu'il n'est pas
spécialement d'idées comment continuer
d'être j'ai pu simplifier la dame je
savais que que c'était afin que la nulle
allaient bientôt signer
mon niveau de jeu pour l'instant correct
après de toute façon le plus important
dans une coupe du monde ce n'est pas
d'avoir de jouer excellemment mais c'est
d'avoir vraiment 00 mauvais jours et
c'est l'objectif que je me suis fixé ici
où je connais mon calendrier évidemment
jusque jusque même en demi finale mais
bon de toute façon c'est un calendrier
prévisionnel on sait jamais ce qu'il
peut se passer par exemple je
m'attendais pas forcément à ce que et
dianov se fasse sortir si rapidement et
je m'attendais probablement à le
rencontrer au troisième tour si je
passais les deux premiers donc voilà
c'est une compétition longue c'est assez
inutile en fait de se projeter si loin
en avant même si au final c'est souvent
les têtes de série qui qui finissent par
arriver au bout
mais dans cette compétition vraiment
tout peut arriver donc le plus réaliste
c'est de regarder tour par toi c'est
beaucoup